The only relationship that you can ever have is a reflection of the one you're having with yourself.
If  you keep hearing the same thing from different people at different times about you,
you need to unpack that baggage.
Stay present in your relationship.
What's up believe nation
It's Evan my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe you have an amazing gift inside you
that I wanna see exploded out of the world now
I started the mentor me series to try to hang around people who've done a lot more than us and by spending a little more
time with them.
Hopefully some of their thoughts their process their mindset set
seeps into us to help us become the best version of ourselves.
So today, we're gonna learn from one of the best Iyanla Vanzant and some of her best relationship advice
mentor me, Iyanla.
So let's kick things off with rule number one it starts with you.
It's amazing to me how much time people spend
worrying about,
lamenting about their relationship with somebody else.
They spend absolutely no time developing a relationship with themselves.
So very often people want to be with somebody,
because they don't want to be by themselves.
Well, here's a question if you don't want to be with you. Why does anybody else want to be with you?
What do you look like from the inside out?
Do you have a clear mind?
Do you have a sweet spirit?
Do you have an open heart?
Have you abandoned you?
Have you abandoned your dreams?
Have you abandoned your gifts?
When was the last time you had an intimate conversation with you?
When was the last time you took you out for a good evening?
When was the last time you?
enjoyed being home in your PJs with you doing something fun.
We live in a world where we expect something or someone outside of ourselves to make us happy.
Remember the only relationship that you can ever have is a reflection of the one you're having with yourself.
So if you want somebody really good and wonderful in your life,
start with you!
Build that relationship
and let's see what happens.
Rule number two. Make sure you're in a healthy relationship
The other day one of my friends asked me just what is a healthy relationship?
You don't have to scratch my head for a minute because I realized that there are many many people who have
no clue, what it is
what it means what it takes to have a healthy relationship.
A healthy relationship is one you want to be it.
Not one that you are in or have been in so long,
you don't know how to leave or one that you used to being in or one that you're in out of habit
or obligation or a sense of responsibility.
A healthy relationship is one that you want to be in because it is good for you
and the other people involved
which brings us to the second element.
A healthy relationship is one in which you feel affirmed,
supported and encouraged.
To be the best person you can be in fact a healthy relationship
Makes you want to be a better person
This means that you can be your authentic self
your real self at all times with the person you're in relationship with.
You have your strengths that are recognized and your weaknesses and shortcomings that are
accepted not criticized.
But that you're also supported in working out and working through
You have your individual talents and interests that are supported and your voice your view your needs
are considered and the things that you do together
in a healthy relationship.
You get to be you as you change and shift and grow without
being expected to be who the other person or people need and want you to be
in order to keep them comfortable.
I think another sign of a healthy relationship is that there's trust
honesty,
respect,
compassion,
forgiveness,
compromise and a shared vision shared interests and a willingness.
To practice all of those principles and live up to them to the best of your
ability.
I hope the relationship is also the one that you're prepared to work for and work on.
Yes! A healthy relationship requires a lot of work
However when you want to be in the relationship
when your passion about the relationship and its health it won't seem like work at all.
A relationship is a living thing it needs to be nurtured and nourished, and if you want to keep the relationship healthy
You can't just sit back and wait for the good times to roll in
You need to initiate it. This means you have to look for ways to create
happy memories all of the time
Even if it means doing something silly that you both enjoy.
Rule number three. Practice good relationship care
Remember that a relationship is a living thing it moves and breathes and heart of the people involved
so when people neglect the life of the relationship those with whom you are having a relationship
The thing is gonna die it's gonna die unnatural death
So it is absolutely essential that you develop and practice good relationship care.
Good relationship care. Things like kindness, and compassion, appreciation,
and the consistent demonstration of you matter to me
You matter to me now this will be different for everyone.
It will be different for different types of relationship,
some people don't care if you ever buy them a birthday presents.
Others will die if you don't!
Some people can survive a week or a monthly call, others want to hear from you every day.
So depending upon the nature of the relationship,
some people will need to hear, I love you,
and thank you, and you look really nice.
Others could give less than hoot,
but it is up to you to pay enough attention to what's going on in the relationship.
So that you can do and demonstrate what's required to nurture it, to nourish it, and to feed it.
Then collecting the people you care about and those who care about you.
That is not gonna turn out well for you
I don't care what kind of relationship you in.
When you stop showing that you care,  when you allow little slights and hurts to add up.
When you stop demonstrating respect and care and concern for one another you are neglecting the relationship.
When you stop connecting, when you stop having fun.
When you stop demonstrating appreciation these are all forms of neglect.
And you know how you can tell when the other person or the people in the relationship are feeling neglected.
They don't start complaining.
They are gonna start complaining
And you see the only reason we complain about anything is because we either know or want things to be different.
We want things to be better, we want something
that we're not asking for or don't know how to ask for.
Rule number four. Communicate.
Let's look at some of the ways that activate
What's required for a healthy relationship.
Let's start here.
Communicate
communicate communicate!
Talk about who you are cuz you're changing day by day moment by moment
Talk about how you are changing, talk about what you want and what you need.
Talk about your strengths, your weaknesses, your fears.
Talk about what you see and what you know and always always be as honest as you can.
And as much as you talk listen, listen with your ears.
Listen with your heart, listen with your soul
And always be willing to hear something new about the other person and never ever ever
Use what you hear as a weapon or tool for dishonorable intentions.
Stay present in your relationship.
If you want your relationship to be healthy and stay healthy, then you have to be in it.
Mentally, emotionally,
physically, and spiritually.
Be mindful not to allow outside
responsibilities, demands and interests to take your mind and heart and your soul out of the heart of the relationship.
If your time and energy and attention is being drawn away,
communicate that.
Communicate what you're up to so that the other person knows and is aware.
Even if they don't like it or don't understand, at least they will know that you're still present.
And rule number five the last one before a very special bonus clip
When something happens with a partner or a friend and even a co-worker or or a supervisor.
And you're bringing up all the other times that you've experienced that in the past.
That's baggage.
When you start your statements about?
Why you do something a certain way or what you're not gonna do because of a certain experience.
That's baggage.
And these are just common everyday things this isn't even the hard stuff,
so I want to give you some unpacking skills.
For just the common everyday normal baggage that we walk around with these human beings.
If one person tells you you're a horse
You don't have to believe that.
If two people tell you your horse you you may want to listen
But by the time three people tell you that your a horse.
You need to check yourself 'cuz I bet you got hay hanging out your mouth and your tail is wagging.
In other words if you keep hearing the same thing from different people at different times about you.
You need to unpack that baggage
and don't hear it as criticism or make people wrong bad, ask them what they mean.
I remember when my my grandson told me that I was mean
And I had heard that but I never paid any attention to it because more, I mean I'm Iyanla Vazanta , It can't be me.
But when I sat, and I listened to him and I realized wait a minute.
He's not the only one saying that to me. I had to hear it, and I had to unpack it.
So when you hear one or two or three unrelated people
telling you the same thing. Don't dismiss them, ask them.
Tell me more about that because there may be some baggage that I have to unpack.
Now I've got a very special
Iyanla clip around giving that I think you're really going to enjoy.
But before that I want you to make the commitment of the day you watch this entire video.
Don't just watch the other video without taking action.
What are you going to commit to changing in your life or in your relationship.
Leave it down the comments below,  make it public. Let us hold you accountable.
I want to see what you are committed to changing. Leave it down below.
Thank you guys so much for watching!
I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your what word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip!
So let's just take a moment and talk about
relationship mass murder. It's called reward and punishment.
What I mean is,
reward and punishment, you know if you do this
I'll do that or I'm not gonna do this because you didn't do that, or when you do this
I'm gonna do that whatever form it takes.
Reward and punishment will kill our relationship.
It's a covert form of manipulation and control.
It's a good granted way to get what you want without asking for it.
It's also a way to try and force people to prove that they care about you.
When you love or care about someone, you must give of your heart and yourself
without expectation of reward or recognition.
Sure, you don't want to always be the one doing and the one giving, but you can't give
expecting something in return.
Unless you ask for it.
Give because it makes you feel good, not because you need one or expect anything.
And when it feels like you are giving giving giving giving and getting nothing in return.
When you feel neglected or unappreciated or overlooked,
or dishonest then you might want to do a relationship assessment.
You might want to consider or reconsider why you're in that relationship.
We've already talked about that. Why? Why are you there? You know as human beings we are
messy and sometimes crazy and very forgetful.
And, yes!
We can and often do take each other for granted. However,
since we train people how to treat us and we give them permission
and an invitation to do so. Only we can say when enough is enough.
Reward and punishment is not only a relationship killer,
it will murder up your sense of value and worth.
Because the other person may have no
idea that you are expecting something in return
for what you're giving, and if you are giving and not getting what you need want or desire.
Either you haven't asked for it, or you're in wrong relationship. You are covering up a need,
and will try to control and manipulate.
The most important word ever!
If you had to think of one word,
that's most important to you or that sums you Apple. That would be like a little beacon.
Hey believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins, Gary Vaynerchuk,
Oprah Winfrey, Will.i.am and Howard Schultz. I have a very special secret video for you.
Check the description for details.